has a genetic blood disorder called
thalassemia she needs frequent blood
transfusions just to keep going
our body doesn't produce blood so we
need to receive it monthly along with
some specific medicines but we haven't
been able to find the medicines we need
for months now and we're slowly dying
because of it
that's because she is also caught in the
crossfire of global politics
finding medication in iran has been
difficult since 2018. that's when the
u.s pulled out of iran's nuclear deal
with world powers and reimposed economic
sanctions
but there is more that prevents mariam
from receiving proper medical care many
international firms have also stopped
doing business with iran as they fear
they may also be sanctioned they include
global distributors of medical supplies
and this has crippled people's access to
medical treatment across the country
thalassemia patients are now among
millions of people whose health is
seriously threatened
when the u.s pulled out of the nuclear
deal we thought it was just a political
situation and that we wouldn't be
affected that much
but more people are dying by the day
547 patients have since died and another
7 000 are at risk as many as 300 of them
may not make it by the end of next year
for yunus arab the loss is all too
familiar this photo is from a picnic who
organized with telesamia patients back
in 2013
those he points to are no longer alive
i'm begging the people who imposed these
sanctions if they have a problem with
our officials they should solve it with
them they shouldn't target ordinary
people they need to know that these
medicines are vital and they must lift
sanctions so we can receive them we
can't live a normal life like this
an eighth round of talks to revive the
2015 nuclear deal is now underway in
vienna
but so far it hasn't produced any
tangible results and with the health of
millions of people at stake in iran any
failure could do worse than damage its
economy resulter al jazeera tehran